music oooh ha ha da romantic
relationships seem pretty simple in the
fairytales I grew up watching boy meets
girl boy likes girl and girl likes boy
boy marries girl and they live happily
ever after
maybe the prince has to slay a dragon
first but after he rescues the girl they
inevitably fall in love with each other
however as we grow up and get older we
realized that romantic relationships are
nowhere near that simple I'm a longtime
fan of Shonen anime anime filled with
epically cool characters who might pick
their nose but man can they kick ass
when the chips are down Shonen was
definitely the first runner I got into
through stuff like Dragon Ball Z and
then eventually Naruto and Inuyasha
obviously I never stopped loving epic
battles but I eventually developed a
love for romance and anime - Inuyasha
had some of it with a love triangle
between Inu Yasha Kagome and kikyo and
that was one of the things that really
drew me to the show yeah there was no
shortage of blood and gore but there was
also a focus on the complicated
relationship between Kagome and Inuyasha
who was still haunted by kikyo I liked
that it wasn't simple it wasn't a pure
and straightforward love you'd get in
the old fairy tales I grew up watching
Inuyasha had feelings for Kagome but he
also still had feelings for his first
love kikyo a relationship wasn't just
the reward at the end of a big battle it
was a constant battle in and of itself
love can be as complicated and messy as
war eventually gravitated to romance
anime like Clannad after story and honey
and clover that acknowledged how
complicated relationships could be
Clannad is not about a brave hero who
comes in slays the dragon and marries
the perfect girl it's about a guy with
issues and a girl with issues helping
each other work through their issues and
enjoying some beautiful but fleeting
moments of happiness in the process then
cut out after story complicated things
even further clown after story went
beyond the boy gets the girl moment it
explores what could happen if maybe
instead of a happily ever after
you have to cope with losing the person
that you love more than anything how
would you handle it could you cope could
you crawl out of the mole
abyss and find moments of happiness
after that honey and clover asks what if
the boy doesn't get the girl maybe the
character is not a hero and the girl is
not even romantically interested in him
or if she is what if she has something
that's even more important to her than
love something that takes priority over
anything else like her art honey and
clover also explores questions like if
you can be happy in a relationship even
after your true love passed away it
acknowledges the complex nature of
relationships and refuses to wrap things
up in a neat little boat at the same
time it shows us that there is more to
life than getting that specific girl and
that you can find moments of happiness
and joy in life even when you're
uncertain by your future even when you
don't have all the answers
that's what we actually experience in
life not that clean pure happily ever
after but a messy form of love that is
sometimes split between multiple people
that sometimes leads to as much pain as
happiness that sometimes isn't required
at all my point is I love these anime
because they reflect the fact that love
is often a broken difficult and
imperfect thing and yet that doesn't
make it any less beautiful in Annika
Denny na Tolstoy writes happy families
are all alike every unhappy family is
unhappy in its own way
the fact that they capture the
complications the beautifully imperfect
nature of love is what makes all these
stories interesting as opposed to the
nice perfect happily ever after kind of
stories and that brings us to domestic
girlfriend another anime that I respect
because it explores the beautiful yet
complicated forms the love can take
domestic girlfriend's about high school
or not xual a wannabe novelist but don't
let him being in high school fool you
this isn't your conventional high school
love story it's much Messier and as a
result much more interesting not tool
loves his high school teacher but in the
first episode he sleeps with another
girl a girl he is not particularly into
right away I respected the show because
the creator's respected me the viewer
they cut through the innocent [ __ ]
they acknowledge the fact that we have
sex even when we're not in love that you
can have sex with one person even when
you're in love with someone else
someone who may never love you back the
series had just started and yet I was
hooked because of the show's honesty as
it turns out rui the girl knoxville
slept with and heena the teacher he's in
love with our sisters and their mother
is getting married to knock souls that
so soon enough all five of them find
themselves living under the same roof
and as you'd expect [ __ ] happens
irui clearly develops feelings for not
school while knoxville is in love with
Hina but it's not that simple he still
cares about Rui he doesn't want to hurt
her and he probably enjoys her attention
too which is why he isn't honest with
her he doesn't insist in the beginning
that he loves someone else and that she
has no shot rather he often leads her on
he continues to kiss her and even ends
up letting her wash him when he has a
cast while they're both completely naked
I mean yeah sometimes there is some
superficial resistance but he usually
goes along with the situation even
though it's misleading to Rui when Hina
moves out to her own place eventually
Natsu lies to Rui instead of telling her
that he's going to see Hina or even
another girl he says he's going to his
Bros house again he keeps her hopes
alive I'm not saying that he's a
terrible person in fact it's a strength
of the show because it knows that we're
not always perfect even if we're not a
terrible person we can end up in a
situation where we end up hurting people
it's hard to tell someone who clearly
likes you and who you also care about
that you don't feel the same way or have
confused feelings or they like them but
like someone else even more like I said
before it's likely that Natsu also
enjoys ruies attention if he's having
problems with Hina Rui is there waiting
for him to make him feel better it's
probably a relationship dynamic that he
doesn't want to give up however his
unwillingness to be honest with Rui ends
up in the emotional roller coaster that
climaxes beautifully and tragically at
the end of episode 10 at this point a
Rui doesn't know for sure about nodules
feeling
for Hina she knows that natural knows
that she likes him and that she clearly
gets jealous when he jokes about other
woman yet as far as she's concerned he
could like her he didn't go for Momo and
the other Club girl while he as I
mentioned before seems pretty receptive
to to his advances earlier on in the
episode I laughed my ass off during the
whole naked bath scene it's just a
hilariously absurd scene from start to
finish with her entering the bathroom
completely naked with them sitting naked
in the bath together with her offering
to wash him with her offering to wash
his front and then with her accidentally
touching his you-know-what and then the
next scene at the restaurant finishes it
off beautifully with kobayashi the
friendly and hilarious owner of the
restaurant explaining to the oblivious
and experienced the ruie that of course
not so Shaun would have had a hard time
then after making you laugh so hard the
absolute goes on to prepare you for
quite the emotional climax and I can't
remember the last time in recent history
that I experienced such a field trip
while watching an anime not school keeps
lying to Roy and not wanting to tell her
that he is going to he knows when rui
discovers through his male friend Fumiya
that he hasn't actually been going to
his place all this time instead of
telling the truth
Nashville says that he's been with Momo
a friend of theirs for meals so she
didn't have to eat alone he says he
didn't want to tell Rui so she wouldn't
get into a bad mood clearly showing
again that he is well aware of her
feelings for him she forgives him
quickly but reminds him that when he
goes to eat with Momo that she is left
to eat alone she asked him to invite her
next time however instead of telling the
truth he continues to lie he lies about
apologizing for his lie and tells Rui
that he is going to make it up to Fumiya
when he is actually going to see Hina
again but Rui believes him once more
what happens next was predictable but no
less impactful as Notts was feeling up
Hina and about to have sex with her a
warrior ooh shows up only to confirm
that not only has not so lied to her
again he is also in love with her older
stir everything rui was working and
hoping for comes crashing down she runs
away leaving two umbrellas her own and
the extra one she brought for not school
because she was concerned about him
myself I'm a sucker for these little
signs of caring like bringing an
umbrella for someone in fact she was
extremely worried about not swell
because when she showed up to Phu Mia's
house who Mia told her that he had left
for home and she didn't see him on the
rainy way back not tool comes home finds
out the Rui isn't there goes searching
for her and eventually finds her
drenched looking extremely sad she slaps
him and then clings to him crying as he
apologizes he's all beat up and dirty
from looking for her everywhere in the
rain with a cast on his life she asked
if he really loves Hina and he tells her
that he's loved her for a long time and
that ends my favorite episode of the
show so far it takes you from laughing
your ass off and brings you on the verge
of tears in one amazing episode it's
clear that nacho cares deeply about the
really the fact that he went searching
for her everywhere with a cast and the
rain makes that clear we empathize with
Rui who has been working so hard and
hoping that nacho will love her
while not suol has been in a way leading
her on while he was committed to her
older sister he lied to Rui left her to
eat alone day after day while he was in
bliss with Hina
however it's not like Natsu is a bad guy
we saw this when he didn't want to have
sex with Momo who was more than ready to
have sex with him although so many other
guys slept with her Natsu couldn't bring
himself to do it he saw that she was
extremely lonely that her parents were
too busy for her and that she often a
alone as a result he saw that she had
cut her wrists and knew that sex was
what Momo exchanged for people simply
spending time with her and easing her
loneliness seeing all this he couldn't
go through with it and ended up making
her food and eating with her instead
it's clear that NASA was not a bad guy
he cares deeply about those around him
he was crushed when rui found out and
telling her the truth
that he loves Hina hurts him a lot
because he cares about her and wants her
to be happy
all the while the girl he is in love
with is a high school teacher and
a student and their even step-siblings
which makes things even more complicated
nothing is simple or black-and-white in
this show there is no happily ever after
love is a battlefield where the casualty
numbers are constantly growing love is
not a prize that you can rest after
attaining it is a constant struggle and
the stakes can be dire you can bet that
he knows professional career will be
severely affected by the truth of their
relationship and that's why I appreciate
this show it isn't pure escapism it
captures how complicated relationships
can truly be something that the old
Disney fairy tales definitely did it
while many shows take many episodes for
a kiss there is sex in the first episode
of this show and yet it continues to
stay interesting it shows us that
relationships can be complicated but in
doing so it also shows us how beautiful
they can be even if the ruies feelings
are never reciprocated even if not soul
doesn't end up with Hina it doesn't mean
that the beautiful moments they share
together were for nothing just like the
meal that not-so had with Momo wasn't
for nothing in the end these little
moments of happiness and beauty make
relationships worth it
even if we don't know for sure what's
gonna happen in the next episode of our
lives and that is it for today's video
thank you for watching let me know how
you liked this video it's definitely a
lot different and a lot of the videos I
make if you did like it make sure to hit
that like button and subscribe thank you
as always to our patrons especially to
our pro tier patrons keelon and
Gilgamesh and toward the one tier
patrons little lady Cady Madi Mac and
ace if you want to support content like
this you can do so over on our patreon
link in the description and until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]